true thompson is getting her very own
makeover from
cousin chicago west please
please for the army khloe kardashian's
two-year-old true
and kim kardashian's three-year-old
chicago played dress-up over the weekend
and had a blast doing each other's
makeup i am so obsessed with her and i
love it so much
chicago expertly glossed true's lips
with none other than some of her mom's
kkw
beauty lipstick lipstick lip gloss lip
liner has everything you'd possibly need
and true had quite the reaction upon
seeing the results of her makeover in
the mirror
the kiddos continued their play date
while shopping for food
at their play grocery store and
scootering around in their princess
costumes
[Music]
e.t caught up with khloe kardashian in
2019 where she opened up about
motherhood
and how daughter true has changed her
life
my favorite part about being a mom i
mean it's so corny but it's just like
no matter how tired you are whatever you
just it's complete bliss
and just when you see your baby and how
happy and like you just get through it
and i was like okay if i could do
anything i could do this and it's just
the best and just the love that you get
that you also get to give and receive
it's just it's beautiful
i think also motherhood just puts life
into perspective and what's important to
you and
and i still think people who don't have
kids there's definitely there's things
that are important to them too because i
felt that way
but i think you just re-evaluate things
like i don't want to do that tonight and
it's okay to say no so i can spend time
with my family you